hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is cameras never seen and today
I am finally watching wreck-it Ralph I
wanted to like do a vanellope inspired
look I know she's in all blue
Frankenstein finger from Halloween it
was from the dollar store and no one ate
them so diabetes I'm going to try to do
good movies for the rest of the month I
know I just did Mamma Mia with Rachel
but that was in that 2018 mindset still
cuz we filmed that in 2018 I'm gonna do
it this year off with some good ones
I feel like recently I've been watching
some stinkers I really love Drecker Alf
- I know it got kind of some flack for
it being not as good as the first but if
this one's better than that one I had
such a good time with that one for
Tamara just saw so hopefully it'll just
wow me I'm looking to cry today looking
to smile with joy I'm looking I just
want those two things okay
let's do it
[Music]
you
this was so good it was so cute it was
something that I don't believe I've seen
before it was funny it was heartwarming
it also made me love the second one even
more or maybe vice versa maybe I like
this one more because of the second one
this one had great character development
first and characters that we do actually
know some of these characters from
classic arcade games but most of them we
don't and it's like developing an actual
voice for them and character for them I
really like this and I really like to
the second now I can confidently say
because I've seen the first that I do in
fact like the second it wasn't just like
because I hadn't seen the first you get
it okay moving on basically it's that
ralph is the bad guy in the game fix-it
Felix and fix-it Felix has the four
hammer of house hammers i hims and fixes
things that ralph wrecks and he's sick
of living in a dumpster totally sick of
not having friends definitely and a sick
of being portrayed as this terrible
person and he wants to go out and fix
that big 2019 mood
last year I said 2018 mood about
everything bad and so this shit was and
we're shaking things up we're going into
this year with positivity what I like
about the very beginning of the movie is
that they've got him portrayed as his
bully who's not a bully he's just big
and he plays one in the game but he
didn't real like he's truly not that I
usually don't enjoy like sympathizing
with bullies and films if you make the
lead character or bully and you're just
supposed to like him a very 80s thing I
feel like I just didn't grow up with and
so now me 2019 Tamara is just like ah
don't I don't get it
I understand why others do ideas it's
not for me this is not that at all he's
starting off as like he's a good guy he
needs to learn some lessons for sure but
he just doesn't want to be bad again
20:19 it's kind of like when you watch a
movie and you hate the villain so much
and the actor did such a good job being
such a shitty villain person that you
hate them in real life I'm looking at
you lady who played the new girlfriend
Meredith black from the remake of Parent
Trap I'm looking at you fix-it Felix the
game celebrates its 30th anniversary of
being a game and all of the game
characters after the arcade closes goes
and celebrates this thing and Ralph
isn't invited and he sees that they're
doing this thing and he's just like a
few yards away in the dumpster and so he
walks over and it's really sad Ralph
needs a medal to show everyone that he's
not a bad guy but he can be a hero as
well and this is when you start to see a
lot of other games and interactions
between other games and it's really fun
he goes into Heroes of duty and it's
this bug killing alien killing game and
the lead character is great she's angry
and aggressive and badass and beautiful
I love her this last week I took pretty
much completely off except for doing my
bird box
Tamara Joe saw where I stayed in my
house so
pretty lakhs week just playing video
games that I got for Christmas from
channel awesome actually
and oh wait let me tell you all week I'm
very good at Super Smash now oh I'm glad
you asked
sheep but seeing all these games just oh
but again I saw the second movie before
seeing this one so I knew that Jane
Lynch's character Calhoun ended up with
what is his name John no not that john c
reilly is ralph
he was a dirty rug Jack Jack Jack
something Jack McDonald's I knew that
they were gonna end up together and I
was very excited to see how that played
out it was really cute their romance was
adorable I really enjoyed it it wasn't
stupid or blame forced it was really fun
while escaping column duty or sorry
heroes of Duty he goes into the sugar
rush game and meets vanellope and I love
her I love her she's the best
I will cosplay her that is all the setup
of the similarities between Ralph and
vanellope is the absolute best she ends
up stealing the medal that he got from
call of duty black ops sorry
heroes of Tootsie and she takes it and
uses it to enter a race she really wants
to race in sugar rush and she's not
allowed because she has a glitch there's
some mysterious backstory there and he's
very upset he goes to get it back from
her he's chasing her around and then he
sees that she's getting bullied from all
the other racers because she has a
glitch she's different
and then he chases all of them away he's
still not happy with her but this
friendship starts to form and it's
really really cute and if this movie
taught me anything it's that you just
find your weirdos find your fellow
weird-ass friends
because they will love you forever they
might destroy your racing car it happens
in a few pages but then they'll put it
back together with the magical hammer
and then you know whatever it's fine
water under the bridge they make her a
car for the race and it's so sweet he's
like I don't think I can build things I
only wreck things and she's like no we
can do it we're gonna expand your
horizons and they do and then they make
the car and it's a mess and he's like I
am so sorry I said I told you and she
like almost hurts crying she loves the
car and it's so cute he protects her he
helps her with muscley big things and
and she is kind to him and is a friend
to him and helps him with you know
emotional things and it's wonderful
I wrote oh no oh no and then again oh no
twice he destroyed her King candy is the
villain of this film and he convinces
Ralph to destroy her car and not let her
race she sits there in sobs and she's
like you are just a bad guy oh my gosh
oh no I am crying he goes back with his
metal though and he doesn't get his way
either because fix-it felix has gone
looking for him and they're gonna shut
down his game tomorrow anyways and while
he's getting this terrible news he sees
on the side of the sugar crush racing
game the vanilla peace face is like one
of the biggest ones there goes back
figures out all of this secret stuff
that king candy has deleted her helps
her get her car back
wha-wha-wha of course of course of
course she races oh the bugs from call
of duty hero of duty are here now in
candy crush it's not candy crush is it
it's sugar rush there we go
got it then in giant letters I wrote oh
my god King candy is turbo I did not see
that coming and I seriously did not see
pic I mean is that dumb did people call
that from the start
I read
that that was a twist on par with any of
em night I also know that I say his name
wrong
Shay Milan Shane Milan I'm not Shambala
cha Milan and night Shyamalan family
he's a sham secret this is such a news
story it came out in 2012 obviously I
know this but it feels so new it feels
like something I've never seen before
it's really sweet you blessin you laugh
you cry
turbo man gets his butt whupped on a
mountain of mentos after he's become
this turbo man King candy spider demon
and it's just it's wholesome for the
whole family
Roth takes care of the bugs with a giant
mentos diet coke fountain beacon and in
doing that he's sacrificing himself
because he's gonna fall into this lava
soda and he's falling and he has a
little heart and he's like alright I am
who I choose to be and then vanellope
comes in with her car and save
and I'm crying here's a reenactment do
you find out that vanellope is the
princess of sugar rush all the people
that were mean to her have to let her
race now she's clearly the best racer
also also she decides she doesn't want
to be princess she wants to be president
I love this movie he gets a house he
gets friends a best friend he is not
living in sadness and traction and it's
the best the second got a lot of flack
for not being as good as the first but I
honestly I really enjoyed this and this
made me like the second one more I
thought there was so much more character
development even after we got all of
this great stuff in this one I don't
know I don't know maybe I'm looking back
on it with rose-colored glasses but I
really liked it rose-colored glasses is
that the phrase rose-colored lenses I
who cares thank you so much for watching
I will see you all next week with
another good movie can you believe it I
can't okay
[Music]
you
[Applause]